HISTORIC BUILDING BUILT IN 1936.
ONE DOOR DOESN'T LOCK AND
ANOTHER DOOR LEAKS WHEN IT
RAINS.
WE TOLD YOU PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
GETTING PRAISE FROM UNUSUAL
QUARTERS ABOUT NORTH KOREA.
THE SAME IS TRUE REGARDING HIS
DECISION TO SLAP TARRIFS ON
STEEL AND ALUMINUM.
MIKE EMANUEL LOOKS AT THIS.
>> STEEL IS STEEL.
>> THE IMAGES WERE STRIKING.
A REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT
SURROUNDED BY UNION WORKERS WHO
TRADITIONALLY SUPPORT DEMOCRATS.
IT DIDN'T END.
THERE THE STEEL AND ALUMINUM
UNION MEMBERS PRAISED THE
PRESIDENT FOR STANDING UP FOR
WORKERS.
>> HE WAS SINCERE ABOUT HELPING
THE STEEL WORKERS OUT.
HE EMPHASIZED OUR STRUGGLES.
>> AND AN ALUMINUM WORKER SAID
HIS FACILITY IS ONLY OPERATING
AT 40% CAPACITY BUT SAID THE
PRESIDENT'S SIGNATURE SHOULD
HAVE AN IMMEDIATE IMPACT.
>> WITH THESE TARRIFS, THIS
GIVES US THE ABILITY TO COME
BACK TO 100% CAPACITY AND INVEST
IN OVER $100-MILLION TO OUR
PLANT AND OVER 300JOBS WILL BE
BROUGHT BACK TO THE COMMUNITY.
>> THEY TALKED ABOUT THIS
PRESIDENT TRYING TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR AMERICAN
WORKERS.
>> I APPLAUD THIS ADMINISTRATION
FOR HAVING THE COURAGE TO LEVY
TARRIFS TO STOP THE CHEATING.
>> AND UNITED STEEL WORKERS
PRESIDENT SAID BY ENSURING
SPLICE FOR STEEL AND ALUMINUM
MR. TRUMP IS SUPPORTING NATIONAL
SECURITY.
A BIG CHANGE FROM WHEN HE SPOKE
AT A RALLY FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
>> TRUMP NEVER SAID IS THERE
ANYTHING I CAN DO TO HELP.
>> TRADITIONAL REPUBLICANS VIEW
THE MEASURES AS ATTACKS.